STELTER, CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR ANA NAVARRO BOTH
JOIN ME.
HELLO TO YOU.
ANA -- GOOD EVENING, EVERYONE.
SO ANA, A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT
THAT THIS WAS THE WORST DAY FOR
TRUMP AND HIS CAMPAIGN.
REMEMBER, WE WERE ON THE AIR
WONDERING OKAY, WHEN IS THIS
APOLOGY TAPE GOING TO BE
RELEASED?
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO SAY?
THEY PREDICTED A HUGE DOWNFALL
FOR HIM.
THAT OBVIOUSLY DID NOT HAPPEN.
AND NOW BILLY BUSH IS SUGGESTING
NBC LOST BECAUSE TRUMP WON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, IT BROUGHT ME BACK
TO WHERE I WAS.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY WHO WAS
FOLLOWING THIS CAMPAIGN AND
FOLLOWING THE POLITICS REMEMBERS
WHERE THEY WERE WHEN THIS
"ACCESS HOLLYWOOD" TAPE WAS
RELEASED.
I WAS ON A PLANE FROM WASHINGTON
TO MIAMI AND I MUST HAVE HAD
GOOD WI-FI BECAUSE I REMEMBER
ALL THE PINGING GOING ON ON THE
PHONES AND THE iPADS ON THE
PLANE.
EVERYBODY ON THE PLANE, THEY
WERE ALL POLITICOS THERE.
THINKING IT'S OVER.
I REMEMBER TRUMP WAS GOING TO
WISCONSIN A COUPLE OF DAYS
LATER.
AND THE BIG WIGS, THE REPUBLICAN
BIG WIGS IN WISCONSIN DECIDED
TON SHOW UP TO THE EVENT.
I REMEMBER MIKE PENCE AND MOTHER
BEING SO UPSET THEY WOULDN'T
SPEAK TO TRUMP FOR DAYS.
AND THEN THE PARTY OF CHRISTIAN
VALUES, THE PARTY OF FAMILY
VALUES ELECTED HIM ONE MONTH
LATER AND TOTALLY FORGOT ABOUT
IT.
IN THE MEANTIME, BILLY BUSH HAS
PAID THE CONSEQUENCES FOR FIVE
YEARS.
AND LOOK, HIS ROLE WAS TO BE A
SOPHOMORIC GUY ON A BUS.
BUT HE'S NOT THE GUY THAT WAS
BOASTING OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
>> HMM.
YOU KNOW, BRIAN, BUSH EXITED NBC
WITHIN TEN DAYS OF THAT TAPE
COMING OUT.
HE'D JUST STARTED AS THE "TODAY"
SHOW'S 9:00 A.M. HOUR HOST.
HE SAYS THAT NBC SACRIFICED HIM.
LISTEN, WHAT DOES THIS SAY ABOUT
WHAT WAS HAPPENING BEHIND THE
SCENES AT NBC?
WASN'T THAT ULTIMATELY THEIR
TAPE AS WELL?
HOW DID THAT TAPE GET OUT?
>> IT WAS NBC'S TAPE.
IT WAS.
AND BUSH HAS COME CLOSER THAN HE
EVER HAS BEFORE TO SAYING HE WAS
FIRED, HE WAS CANCELED.
FIVE YEARS AGO WE DIDN'T HAVE
THAT PHRASE CANCEL CULTURE THE
WAY EVERYBODY KNOWS IT TODAY.
BUT BILLY BUSH IS AN EXAMPLE OF
LEADERSHIP, IN THIS CASE NBC, AT
AN INSTITUTION THAT DECIDED TO
CANCEL SOMEONE JUST TO GET OVER
THE BAD PRESS.
JUST TO AVOID THE BAD PRESS.
AND NOW I THINK FIVE YEARS LATER
WE CAN VIEW THIS IN A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY.
AND SAY THAT WAS AN INJUSTICE.
YOU KNOW, THE WAY BILLY BUSH WAS
TREATED.
THAT THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO GET
A SHORT-TERM GAIN, JUST LIKE GET
RID OF HIM, BUT A LONG-TERM
DAMAGE THAT WAS DONE AS A
RESULT.
IT TOOK YEARS FOR BILLY BUSH TO
FIND WORK AGAIN.
AND NOW HE'S THE HOST OF
"EXTRA."
HE SAYS ON INSTAGRAM TONIGHT, "I
HAVE A PLAN TO USE THIS
EXPERIENCE TO HELP HEAL THE
CULTURE."
AND I'M REALLY CURIOUS WHAT HE
MEANS BY THAT.
WITH THE FIVE YEARS THAT WE'VE
HAD SINCE.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME I THINK WHEN
WE LOOK BACK AT THAT NIGHT FIVE
YEARS AGO, DON, WE CAN SEE EVEN
MORE CLEARLY WHAT AN INJUSTICE
THIS WAS AND WHAT AN UPSIDE DOWN
WORLD THIS WAS, THAT BILLY BUSH
WAS THE ONE THAT SUFFERED FROM
ALL OF THIS AND DONALD TRUMP
BENEFITED.
AND IT REMINDS ME THAT THOSE OF
US IN THE MEDIA, WE DO NEED TO
WORK TO CALL OUT INDECENCY.
INDECENCY IS NOT PARTISAN.
IT'S NOT LEFT OR RIGHT.
IT'S ABOUT RIGHT VERSUS WRONG.
AND FIVE YEARS FROM NOW, YOU
KNOW, I HOPE WE'RE NOT HAVING
THESE SAME CONVERSATIONS.
I HOPE WE'VE MADE PROGRESS AS A
SOCIETY SO WE'RE NOT HAVING THE
SAME CONVERSATIONS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> WELL, LISTEN, LET ME JUST SAY
THIS.
I THINK IF YOU ASK BILLY BUSH HE
WILL SAY -- I THINK HE WOULD
AGREE THAT IT ISN'T -- I THINK
HE BELIEVES THAT MAYBE HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DISCIPLINED.
>> HE WHY, HE SCREWED UP THAT
DAY.
>> HE SCREWED UP.
BUT BEING FIRED AND THEN AFTER
THAT PEOPLE NOT WANTING TO HIRE
HIM BECAUSE OF THAT.
I MEAN, WAS THAT FAIR TO BILLY
BUSH WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
OVERALL BIG PICTURE?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S EVOLVED
IN THIS KIND OF CONVERSATION
ABOUT CANCEL CULTURE, SO TO
SPEAK, THAT YOUR WORST MOMENT
DOES NOT DEFINE YOU AS A HUMAN
BEING.
HOWEVER, WHEN IT'S PART OF A
PATTERN, AND THAT'S WHAT WE
LEARNED ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, PART
OF A PATTERN, THEN IT IS
SOMETHING TO TAKE SERIOUSLY.
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, BRIAN?
I HATE THE TERM CANCEL CULTURE.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> WE USE OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
BECAUSE IT'S A TERM THAT DOESN'T
ALLOW FOR NUANCE.
CANCELING HARVEY WEINSTEIN FOR
WHAT HE DID OR CHARLIE ROSE OR
MARK HALPERIN IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN PENALIZING SOMEBODY LIKE
BILLY BUSH FOR SAYING SOMETHING
STUPID AND BEING AT THE WRONG
PLACE AT THE WRONG TIME AND
BEING THE ONE WHO CARRIED THE
BLAME SO NBC COULD SOMEHOW
CONTINUE GOING ALONG.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T LIKE THAT
TERM, CANCEL CULTURE.
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT CANCELING.
SOMETIMES IT'S CONSEQUENCE
CULTURE.
SOMETIMES IT'S ACCOUNTABILITY
SOMETIMES IT'S RESPONSIBILITY
CULTURE.
AND I DO THINK THAT AS WE LOOK
AT IT IN HINDSIGHT WHAT HAPPENED
TO BILLY BUSH WAS TOO MUCH AND
IT WAS NOT -- AND EVEN MORE SO
WHEN YOU PUT IT IN PERSPECTIVE
TO WHAT HAPPENED TO DONALD
TRUMP, WHICH WAS ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
>> YEAH.
ANA, THAT VIDEO -- THE NIGHT
THAT VIDEO CAME OUT YOU WERE
CERTAINLY FIRED UP ON THIS SHOW.
LET'S PLAY IT.
>> OH, LORD.
>> EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN IS
GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION, WHAT DID YOU DO THE
DAY YOU SAW THE TAPE?
OF THIS MAN BOASTING ABOUT
GRABBING A WOMAN'S [ BLEEP ].
PERIOD.
>> WILL YOU PLEASE STOP SAYING
THAT WORD?
MY DAUGHTER IS LISTENING.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
DON'T TELL ME YOU'RE OFFENDED
WHEN I SAY [ BLEEP ] BUT YOU'RE
NOT OFFENDED WHEN DONALD TRUMP
SAYS IT.
>> EXACTLY.
>> I'M NOT RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
HE IS.
>> YES.
>> SO DON'T ACT OUTRAGED AND
OFFENDED WHEN I SAY IT WHEN
YOU'RE NOT OFFENDED WHEN THE MAN
YOU'RE SUPPORTING IS SAYING IT.
>> ANA, YOU HAVE BEEN CONSISTENT
THEN, EVEN IN 2016.
YOU'RE CONSISTENT NOW.
YET HERE WE ARE IN 2021 WITH THE
GOP STILL PUTTING ALL THIS STOCK
IN TRUMP, STILL MAKING EXCUSES
FOR HIM, EVEN FOR THE VIOLENT
INSURRECTION.
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT, WHO
THE INSURRECTIONISTS WERE SAYING
THEY WERE GOING TO HANG HIM.
THE REACTION THERE.
I MEAN, THAT WAS SORT OF A
PRECURSOR FOR WHAT WAS TO COME.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, LISTEN, FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
THAT VIDEO ON BECAUSE I THINK I
LOOK REALLY CUTE.
I NEED TO LOSE A LOT OF WEIGHT.
>> SAME HERE.
BOTH OF US.
>> BUT I REALLY DO THINK IT WAS
A HARBOR OF THINGS TO COME.
WE HAVE SEEN SINCE FIVE YEARS OF
HYPOCRISY FROM REPUBLICANS,
WILLING TO JUSTIFY AND DEFEND
ANYTHING AS LONG AS THEY CAN
STAY NEAR POWER AND THEY CAN BE
PART OF THE CIRCLE OF POWER.
SO WE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE WHO CALL
THEMSELVES CHRISTIAN INCLUDING
PEOPLE LIKE MIKE PENCE CLUTCH
THEIR PEARLS WHEN I QUOTE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ABOUT SOMETHING AND, YOU KNOW,
BEAT THEIR CHEST ABOUT BEING
FAITHFUL CATHOLICS OR FAITHFUL
CHRISTIANS OR FAITHFUL WHATEVER,
AND YET GO AND DEFEND SOMEBODY
THAT'S CONSISTENTLY SHOWN SUCH
LACK OF MORALITY AND HAVING
ABSOLUTELY NO CONSCIENCE OR
PRINCIPLES AND CERTAINLY NO
VALUES.
>> YEAH.
>> AND IT WAS -- BUT YOU
THIS CAME AFTER HE MOCKED A
REPORTER WITH A DISABILITY.
THIS CAME AFTER HE CALLED JOHN
McCAIN A LOSER FOR BEING
CAPTURED AND SAID HE DIDN'T LIKE
P.O.W.s AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CAPTURED.
SO THIS IS, YOU KNOW -- IT WAS
JUST -- BUT IT WAS PROBABLY THE
WORST, BECAUSE WE WERE HEARING
IT ON TAPE.
THE GUY WANTING TO BE LEADER OF
THE FREE WORLD BOASTING OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
I THINK SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALSO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT I THINK IT
CHANGED AND INFLUENCED THE "ME
TOO" MOVEMENT.
>> AH, YES.
>> I THINK DONALD TRUMP'S
ELECTION WAS THE CATALYST TO GET
WOMEN TO SPEAK UP AND STAND
LOCKING ARMS BEHIND EACH OTHER,
AND THAT HAS BROUGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY TO MANY OTHERS.
MAYBE DONALD TRUMP GOT AWAY WITH
IT, OR HE DID, BUT MANY OTHERS
HAVE NOT BECAUSE WOMEN GOT
PISSED AND GOT ACTIVE BECAUSE OF
DONALD.
>> BRIAN, I'M UP AGAINST THE
CLOCK.
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR, NO ONE
IS SAYING THAT BILLY BUSH DIDN'T
DO ANYTHING WRONG, WHAT HE DID
AND SAID WAS WRONG, BUT IT'S
ABOUT BALANCED, RESPECT --
>> P